what's your advice to your younger self
so I recently challenged my mastermind
group to come up with a video to share
that gave advice to the younger self and
one of my members rich had an amazing
piece and I wanted to share a quick clip
of it for you guys rich I love you man
you do great work just have more faith
believe more worried less do more think
less I'll tell you spend more time
working on yourself than working on your
business spend more time developing
yourself personally spiritually
psychologically develop yourself more
work on more personal development stuff
rather than just figuring out technical
stuff about cameras or about you know
computers or software just were the more
you can develop yourself the better it's
going to be for you because really the
end of the day having ten years to look
back at stuff mindset is more important
than skill set so the two things that I
love about this video one was how he
said which I love you man it felt
heartfelt to me and two I love the point
at the end about mindset being more
important than skill set and I think
going through that exercise to be able
to give your younger self advice sets
you up now for what you should be paying
attention to ongoing as well because
often that advice is still applicable
today so I'm curious for you guys what
advice would you give the younger
version of yourself leave it in the
comments below and I'm going to join a
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon